[Music]
I just try to be in the moment it was
the great energy it was amazing it was
so much fun but I don't really quite
remember oh no seriously but it was very
cool and I have this one on my side so
I'm pretty lucky
speaking of this one on your side we saw
that you guys you did a little double
dating it's really fun and I just wanted
to get to know Vanessa and she's gonna
be with us you know every step of the
way so it's just you know it was awesome
just to have dinner and chill and there
might be a little there might be a
little competition here is your little
dam right okay throw it down we got four
sevens so man we're gonna start slow
we're gonna slow what do you think it is
about the sort of the personalities the
fact that you're you know your chemistry
so gray obviously you get along
I think it's you've got to have a good
balance between fun and work and I think
we we nail that I think we're goofy but
we know when to work hard we know into
like you know knuckle down and get all
the steps down so yeah I think that's
really a humor like I said we've mean
work we're not if we lose it's because
not because we didn't try it hard but
we're also gonna have fun - yeah like
she she's hilarious and I just try to
feed off that I mean like every time I
learn a new move it's it's a really
comical thing to watch it's really
really bad it's great on game day
and I gotta ask has a new mom how hard
is it for you to be what I know you're
away during rehearsals but both you here
on show night will show hot it's hot
this seems so much yeah I mean it's like
potty a hot left at heart it's very
surreal actually but I just can't wait
to get home tonight